we made peace a symbol of our in the
name of peace we together here now oh
Lord please make these days of vows on
this Earth f with peace TV the solution
for
Humanity oh you believe give
charity for the pleasure of
Allah the pleasure of
Allah oh you
believe read the
Quran every night of
Ramadan night of
Ramadan welcome oh
Ramadan it is
Ramadan dear brothers and sisters in
Islam and
Humanity May the peace blessings and
mercy of Allah be upon you all and
welcome to this the first in a series of
interviews and question and answer
sessions regarding Ramadan entitled
Ramadan a date with Dr
zakya I I'm your host Yousef Chambers I
myself will be interviewing Dr zaka Nike
and asking him your
questions regarding important topics to
do with Ramadan Ramadan has a very
special place in my own heart 16 years
ago after a struggle of more than 10
years I stumbled upon
Muslims deep in the worship of Allah
during this blessed month Ramadan after
a struggle of more than 10 years I went
through chrisan Christianity Hinduism
jism materialism socialism and many
other isms that you and I wouldn't even
recognize even if I triy to tell you you
wouldn't recognize them Subhan Allah now
brothers and sisters during this blessed
month of Ramadan Allah revealed the last
Testament his last Testament to mankind
the Quran and the Quran is still with us
can you imagine this this is why this
month of Ramadan is so special to the
Muslims not just the Muslims but
non-muslims indeed I came to Islam
during this blessed month for when I
encountered Muslims that were not
practicing their Dean and then suddenly
they started practicing in that one
month I felt obliged to look into the
books of Islam and search for the truth
I found the truth and a few days later I
started fasting a few days later I took
the shahada alhamdulillah this blessed
Islam is just too good for people to
overlook brothers and
sisters
Ramadan the month of Mercy the month of
forgiveness the month when the Blessed
Quran was revealed to the prophet
Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam this
series of programs is so incredibly
important for you and for me to make
sure that we observe and we watch
in this program as I said I will be your
host brothers and sisters and I will be
joined every single day by a person who
you do not need much of an introduction
to his Acumen and his profession
originally he was a medical doctor
trained as a medical doctor and once he
told me that he considered himself to be
a medical doctor a doctor of the human
body latter he explained to me that I
became a doctor of the human soul and
this is obviously referen to the fact
that Quran and Sunnah had entered his
heart and he had felt the need to give
daer upon that for the last 11 years my
dear brothers and sisters he has
delivered over a thousand lectures on
the international Arena on television
print-based Media Radio and he's the
author of many important books on the
topic comparative religion and Islam his
critical analysis and his ability to
quote verbatim from Many religious
scriptures the world over being all of
the major religions in the world my dear
brothers and sisters is unparalleled
therefore he's a resort for Humanity and
I furthermore would suggest that without
further Ado I should invite him to join
us Dr Zakia Abdul Karim Nike
alhamdulillah please have a
seat Dr Zak is there any information
that you need to impart to the viewers
of Peace TV before we start this long
series of interviews and question and
answer sessions regarding Ramadan a date
with Dr zakya
Al before we start this long series of
episodes Ramadan date with Dr zaker I
would like to make my position very
clear that I consider myself to be a
student of knowledge I consider myself
to be a Tali
I don't consider that I'm a scholar to
give fatwas Islam ruling is concerned
and as far as this topic on Ramadan
there are various issues and there are
various differen of opinions as far as
different Scholars are concerned as far
as different schools of thought are
concerned since there are only four
verses in the Quran dealing directly
with Ramadan that's Sur Bak chapter 2
verse number 183 verse number 184 verse
number 185 and verse number 187 there
are indirectly another few versus but
directly only four verses so most of the
rulings are based on the Hadith and some
Scholars have used had some have used
MTH some have used so as far as what
I'll be
answering it will basically be the views
of different Scholars only I'll be
selecting those Scholars who I feel have
quoted on the basis of Quran and say so
it may not agree with some of the
viewers view which they used to our
opinion should always be based on Quran
and say Hadith when require I may give
the difference of opinion different
Scholars I'll name the scholars if
required most of the time I may not name
but I would like to make it very clear
at the outset that all the answers as
far as Ramadan issues are concerned none
of them are my own answers they are
basically some all the other Scholars
who have said it and I'll try my level
best to name the scholars whenever
required so that no one feels that I'm
trying to give my own opinion but I
always believe that the answer should be
based on Quran and say had so that Al
time a level best and
as far as possible whenever I quote
Hadith I will try and give the
references whether some say bukari or
say Muslim the volume number as as
Hadith number so that people can you
know check it up and as far as possible
that beting will be authentic and
similarly with the of the Quran and
that's my normal method of giving
replies so that
people whenever they get the answer they
get from Authentics s Quran and say and
whatever right or good that comes out
from my mouth will be from Allah subhana
wa tala and whatever wrong and mistakes
that come from my mouth will be from my
side and from the side of the Shan so I
seek Refuge with Allah from sitting
theur and I pray to Allah subhana tala
that may this series be beneficial for
all of us including the viewers
insh now to the show this show comprises
of two separate parts the first part
will be a live interview between between
myself and Dr Zaki andik regarding the
topic a chosen topic about Ramadan and
the second part will be your questions
answered by Dr zakya Nike on the
particular topic of the day
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters I'd
like to review the list of topics that
we will be discussing inshallah over the
next 32 days and by the way brothers and
sisters you might be wondering why on
Earth we're covering 32 days are we
strange no we're not strange in naturual
fact we're so concerned about all the
brothers and sisters all in different
parts of the worlds that of course that
Ramadan occurs at slightly different
days one day here and there different so
we're covering all the world and all the
Muslims inshallah may Allah accept it
from us
inshallah right without further Ado
let's go through the list then brothers
and sisters the first day topic number
one episode number one will be let's
welcome Ramadan that's today the second
episode common errors committed by
Muslims during Ramadan the third
introduction to Ramadan the fourth when
is fasting obligatory and
Exempted number five acts that
invalidate the fast and acts prohibited
during fasting number six acts permitted
during fasting number seven acts
recommended and discouraged during
fasting number eight
and number nine objectives of fasting
number
10 benefits of fasting episode number 11
Ramadan the month of repentance and 12
Ramadan the month of
supplications number 13 and
14 part one and two number 15 that's
almost well that's halfway through
Ramadan brothers and sisters Ramadan the
month of the Quran part one number 16
Ramadan the month of the Quran part two
17 zaka part one 18 zaka part two 19
zaka part
three number
20 inshallah just in time for the last
10 days of Ramadan where you could try
to find that auspicious night number
21 number 22 episode number 22 Ramadan
the month of self-improvement and Islam
part one and followed by on the 23rd
Ramadan the month of selfimprovement and
Islam part two and the third day after
that episode 24 Ramadan the month of
self-improvement and Islam part three
episode 25 Ramadan the month of
self-improvement in Islam part four
episode 26 da to non-muslims in the
month of Ramadan episode 27 is kadf
fasts fidia and kafar fasts episode 28
is sighting of the Moon episode 29 is
zakat alra episode 30
is and episode 31 is voluntary fasts and
prohibited
fasts and finally last but not least
episode
32 from this Ramadan until the next Dr
Zak particularly what are your comments
on the selection of these topics
alhamdulillah all the topics that we
have discussed and have categorized
alhamdulillah into different days so
that it will benefit the viewers knowing
about the details of the month of
Ramadan and it will also help me in
replying to the question they're going
to post to me because many of times some
of the questions they will overlap so I
will see to it that I reply specifically
on the day that the topic have asked and
I see to it that I will reply in detail
on that specific day and if it's
supposed to be mentioned earlier then
maybe I will just give a brief comment
but one point to be noted is that most
of these topics I feel should be
discussed much before the month of
Ramadan starts there may be few topics
which may be discussed any time of the
year for example voluntary fast these
topics can be
discussed any time of the year there are
some topics like and which should be
discussed just before the last 10 days
which we'll be doing inshallah and some
topics
like should be discussed just before Eid
but most of the topics that we'll be
discussing they should be discussed
before
Ramadan for example we will be
discussing andur on the eighth day we'll
be discussing things or acts that
invalidate the fast on the fifth day and
we will be starting our fast on the
first day of Ramadan so it doesn't make
sense so actually we should start much
before at least three or four weeks
before the month of Ramadan begins but I
do agree that the reason we are starting
from day one of Ramadan is because more
of Muslims
watch the Islamic programs in the month
of Ramadan than on any other days so the
viewership in the month of Ramadan is
much higher so alhamdulillah it's right
that we're starting on day one but it
should be shown again maybe after a few
months so that it is a preparation for
the next Ramadan mashallah well all the
topics Dr zaka seem to have been
logically positioned and scientifically
chosen by yourself um one thing I do
appreciate though is that um we've added
in the first couple of topics which are
let's welcome Ramadan so that's very
logical that the first day everybody's
very keen to you know go about Ramadan
in the proper ways so would be that'll
be very beneficial for the viewers and
secondly comment errors which are
committed by Muslims during this month
the second day so first two days are
Health warnings if you like yeah
alhamdulillah now let's go straight into
the questions regarding the preparation
what did the alai wasallam do in order
to welcome Ramadan what was his
preparation for
Ramadan is mentioned in s bukari r
number three book of fasting Hadith
number 1969 the wife of the prophet AA
may Allah be pleased with her she says
that the prophet he never fasted any
month completely except the month of
Ramadan and in no month did he fast as
many days as he fasted in the month of
shaan so from this Hadith we come to
know that Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Ali wasallam in order to welcome the
month of Ramadan he used to start he
used to prepare himself and fast more in
the previous month that is the month of
shaan that was his his way how he used
to prepare for the month of Ramadan and
further if you read
in chapter number 50 Hadith number 3451
which says that t may Allah be pleased
with him he said on the authority of his
father that his father that is his
grandfather he said whenever the prophet
saw the new moon used to always pray to
Allah subhana tala and say oh Allah
bless us in this month and is to mention
the name of that month and then say that
please keep us steadfast in faith in
this month this was the way the prophet
always used to pray to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala whenever he saw a new moon it
wasn't specifically only for the new
moon of the month of Ramadan but it was
for all new moons when used to see and
his special way of welcoming the month
of Ramadan was that he used to mention
about the coming of this blessed month
to the people
and it's mentioned in mus Ahmed R number
two page number 230 Hadith number
7148 where Prophet M sallallahu Ali
wasallam used to tell the people that oh
people this blessed month is approaching
you and Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the gates of hell
will be closed and the Devils will be
Chained and in this month there is a
night which is better than a thousand
months and if anyone is deprived of
Allah subhanahu wa tala's blessing in
this month he's truly a deprived person
so here we come to know that this is how
Prophet Mall Al wasallam used to welcome
this month and he used to tell the good
news of the Blessed month to come to all
the people mashallah the next question
to you is what should we do when Ramadan
approaches the first thing we should do
is we should thank Allah subhana wa
ta'ala for making us witness this
blessed month of Ramadan once again and
we have to thank him for his mercy and
we have to ask forgiveness in this month
so that all our previous sins will be
forgiven and we have to thank him for
All The N he has given us all the
blessings all the love this is the best
month and Allah subhana says in the
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number
185 it
says which means that Ramadan is the
month in which the Quran was revealed
as a guidance for
mankind and
signs for guidance and judgment between
right and
wrong and Allah further says in the
Quran in Surah Bak chapter number two
verse number 183 Allah
says oh you who
believe all you believe fasting was
prescribed to you as it was prescribed
to people who came before you so that
you may
learn
self-restraint the word used here
is similar to tawa so that you learn God
Consciousness so that you learn py so
that you learn righteousness so this is
the month in which a person can become
more righteous this is the time when a
tawa can be the highest and this is a
month it is an annual training it is a
sort of an overhauling of the body how
we have that every Machinery requires
some sort of servicing maybe every 3
months maybe every year and if you allow
me to call the human
beings as the best Machinery in the
world doesn't it require a servicing or
overhauling so Ramadan is an annual
overhauling of the human body it is a
spiritual and moral training for the
human
being and it is a purification of the
body mind and soul this is the month
where we can increase our tawa we can
increase our patience and we can derive
the benefits and the guidance from the
Quran Subhan
Allah beautiful answer next question
what are your particular words of advice
regarding the on the occasion of Ramadan
approaching us my advice would be that
every Muslim he or she should make it a
point that they should make a resolution
that they should fast each and every day
of this blessing month of Ramadan and we
should try and acquire all the benefits
of this month and we should not waste a
single minute in this blessed month on
things which are and try and concentrate
as much as possible in Remembering Allah
subhana wa taala we we should try and
look for his Mercy we have to try and
ask for
forgiveness we have to try and seek for
his love and we have to try and increase
our piety our righteousness and our
patience and our beloved Prophet mmad
wasallam said in s bukari verm number
three in the book of fasting Hadith
number 1 1903 our beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallah Ali wasallam said
anyone who does not
leave the false action and false
speech Allah subhana wa ta'ala does not
care if he leaves his eating and
drinking that means if a person does not
abstain from false action and false
speech Allah subhana does not care if
you abstain from food and drink that
means your fasting will not be accepted
unless you stay away from false action
and false speech
and a beloved Prophet M wasallam he also
said it's
mentioned which is written in mus Ahmed
R number two page number 230 Hadith
number 7148 and it also appears in sunai
chapter number five Hadith number
21106 where our beloved Prophet malli
wasallam said oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching and Allah has ordained for
you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the Devils they will
be
Chained and this month is the
night which is better than a thousand
months and if a person is deprived of
the blessings in this month he's truly a
deprived person so we have to make it a
point that we gain the benefits of this
blessed
month our beloved Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned s bukari number
three in the book of fasting Hadith
number
191 our beloved Prophet mallalli
wasallam
said that anyone who fasts in this
month with faith seeking the of Allah
subhana wa taala all his past sins will
be
forgiven that means if we truly with
sincerity fast in this month and seek
the reward of Allah subhana wa tala all
our past sins will be forgiven imagine
it is such an easy way to have our sins
forgiven of the past and our beloved
Prophet M wasam also said it's mentioned
s
bukari m number three in the book of
fasting Hadith number 1904 this is a
very long Hadith which has basically
Four Points
our beloved Prophet Mahi wasallam said
that all the children of Adam all the
Deeds that they do are for themselves
except for fasting fasting is for me and
I will reward
him and he further said that fasting is
a
shield it prevents you from
sin and the person who observes the fast
he should abstain from
obscenity from yelling
and from ignorance and if someone yells
at him or abuses him he should say I'm
fasting I'm
fasting and the third point of beloved
Prophet said in this Hadith is that I
swear by Allah in whose hand is the soul
of Muhammad s wasallam that the breath
of a faster the person who fasts is
sweeter to Allah subhana wa ta'ala than
the scent of
musk and he finally said in the Hadith
that there are two things when a faster
is happy and looks forward to it the
first is when he breaks the Fast and the
second is when he meets the Lord Allah
subhana
tala and further it's mentioned in the
Quran in Surah n chapter number 24 verse
number 31 it says oh you
believe truly have faith in Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and seek the Bliss
that means try and enter Jah it's
mentioned Sur chapter number
46 verse number 13 and
14 that those are the people who worship
none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and they are stedfast in faith the word
Isam they steadfast in faith that
there's only one Allah and no one else
and they shall not have any fear nor
that sh grief these are the people who
are the people of
paradise and they shall be rewarded for
all the goods they have
done so this is advice for the people
that they should take the best of this
month and should not spend time on
things and spend their time in the
worship of Allah and reming Allah
subhana wa taala and asking for
forgiveness masallah next question is
you've alluded to that in some of the
beautiful hadiths you've mentioned just
now but um what specific reason is it
that Ramadan is called the month of
forgiveness or is known as the month of
yes as I rightly mentioned earlier that
a beloved Prophet Mahi wasallam said
it's in a Hadith ofari R number three
book of fasting Hadith number 1901 our
beloved Prophet mallalli wasallam said
that if anyone fasts in the month of
Ramadan with the proper intention with
faith and asking for reward of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala he will forgive all
all your pasts and this message is
further repeated in the mus
Ahmed volume number three Hadith number
11524 where it's mentioned that any
person who fasts in the month of
Ramadan with the proper intention
seeking the reward of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
he will have all his previous sins
atoned and further it's mentioned in say
Muslim
volume number one Hadith number 450 our
beloved Prophet Muhammad sallam said
that the time between the five
prayers and the two jumas and from one
Ramadan to the other is the time for
expiration of your sins this is a time
where you can have all your sins
forgiven and our beloved Prophet M also
said it's mentioned in s Muslim where
number four in the book of Toba Hadi
number 6644 our beloved Prophet malli
wasallam said that Allah subhana ta'ala
at night time a person who asks for
forgiveness he forgiv the sin for the
sin he has committed in the day and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in the daytime
he forgiv the sin for a person who ask
forgiveness for the sin has committed
night so this is the best month of
forgiveness the month of Ramadan where
you can easily have your sins forgiven
because the Gates of Heaven open and the
gates of hell are closed therefore it's
called the month of forgiveness allahar
no wonder everybody wants to be active
in that month now we know why Subhan
Allah Dr zakya um are there any
particular activities a Muslim should
concentrate upon during this blessed
month of Ramadan and of course we should
relate to you the importance of the fact
that our viewers really can gain massive
benefit by knowing
specific activities they can get
involved in and they can start planning
the Ramadan now yes I believe that this
is a very good question because most of
the activities will'll be dealing as
time goes on in the episode but just to
give a brief outline I will just specify
a few important because the whole answer
will take very long the few important
points that will be noted is that number
one it is the Nia the Nia is very
important the Nia of fasting should only
be for Allah subhana wa tala and for a
fasting to be accepted the is important
so making the is very important without
which the fasting will not be accepted
number two is observing the Sunnah of
the
fast that we'll be dealing in detail in
the next few days but just a point to be
noted that one of the important Sunnah
is that we should
have as late as possible that is just
before the break of dawn just before
Salah and we should break our fast have
as early as possible immediately after
Sunset furthermore in this blessed month
we should be careful
and we should avoid all things which are
prohibited which are Haram and all
things which are makr and this is the
best opportunity where a person if he
has certain activities which are against
the Sharia where whether he doing Haram
activities or Mak activities this is the
best time he can abstain from it and
that will be a good habit which insha
may abstain maybe throughout his life
for example if a person is habituated to
drinking alcohol if he can abstain from
having alcohol from the break of dawn to
Sunset he can abstain from it from the
kle to the Grave similarly we should
take care that we should should abstain
from the things which are
makr for example it is Mak to stand and
drink water and if you Hab to that so
see to it that in this month of Ramadan
while having water we should sit down
this for the sun of the Prophet so it's
a good month in which you can abstain
from the Haram activities which you have
been doing maybe some of them or the
makro activities
furthermore it's a good time where you
can Implement many of the of the prophet
in your day-to-day life for example
maybe sporting a
beard many Muslims don't have a beard so
it's a good month where you can follow
the Sunnah of the
Prophet the Sunnah of the Prophet about
the duas of when you enter the home when
you leave the toilet the Dua that is
there when you're traveling in a
vehicle so this is a good month in which
you can adopt as as much as Sunnah as
possible so that we can be on the
straight path this is a very good month
where you should see to it that you
should offer the Salah not only the five
times Salah which is a f even try and
offer as many Na and
Sunnah and if you're not habituated to
reading in congregation see to that read
in congregation and as far as possible
go to the MOs for the
Salah in this month we should be
particular that we do not miss the T
many people think and it is a fact that
it is a Sunnah but many people think
that because it's a Sunnah we can Miss
T is a very important sunah though it's
not a but every Muslim should make it a
point that as far as possible they
should attend T because of the blessings
it has so T is very important which
Muslim should never
miss and when we offer T many of us we
rush through T because we want to
complete the Quran and many of them read
the T 100 miles per hour we should read
the T with patience at a moderate pace
so that people can understand what is
the Commandment of Allah subhana
tala and that if time permits and if
possible we should try and do in the
last 10 days and while doinga make it a
point that we don't socialize many will
make a mistake of socializing during the
whole purpose of is
defeated first further more we should do
more Dua in this month we should do more
supplications this is the month of
Dua
and we should do more spend time in
Remembering Allah subhana wa tala and
also worshiping him this is the month in
which we should try and read as much as
Quran as possible besides reciting the
Quran Arabic if you know Arabic as a
language then there's no problem but if
you don't know then also read the
translation of the Quran in the language
we understand the best if you understand
English read in English if you
understand Udu read in Udu read it in
the language understand the best but
while resting the Quran for which you'll
get a Saab also read the translation of
the Quran so that you can Implement on
the guidance of Allah subhana wa tala if
possible read the Quran once in every
seven days or at least
read one J every day so that you
complete the Quran at least once in the
full month of Ramadan in this month try
and read as much as Hadith that possible
but see to it that you read the
authentic
Hadith and the best book on Hadith is
the book of say alkari then is say
Muslim you can read the other also but
read authentic books on read books on
the lifestyle and the SE of the Prophet
Muhammad s
wasallam see to it that if you have not
given the zakat please give the the
zakat which is an obligatory
charity and every rich person who has a
saving of more than the nisab level more
than 85 grams of gold he or she should
give
2.5% of his saving every lunar in
charity that is zakat and many people
they do not calculate the zakat properly
they make it a point that you calculate
the zakat honestly and it is better to
give little bit more rather than to give
less so calculate it properly and see to
it that you give your zakat and this
Ramadan is a month of generosity it's a
month of s and you get 10 times more
reward for good deeds so this is the
month where you should do maximum
charity and besides that we should make
it a point that during this month we
should be cheerful many of the Muslims
they look dull they look gloomy you
should be cheerful and
happy and we should give more time to
our family
many times we neglect our family which
is secr that we give more time to our
family and do all these activities
collectively we should also
have to the people around you that means
we should deal with the other human
beings with Mercy with love with care if
they've done some mistakes that forgive
them this is the month of forgiveness if
you have done something wrong to them
for
forgiveness live with the people around
you with love care
and with
affection we should to that means
Ponder on the things see to it that you
plan your month of
Ramadan plan it properly and see to it
that you do not waste not even a minute
not even a second this is the month of
gaining and this month is the best month
for self-improvement
also and besides that should also make
it app point to do
islah with your other Muslim brothers
and
sisters it's also the best month to do
dawa that is convey The Message of Islam
to the
non-muslims so it's my request to the
brothers and sisters that plan your
month efficiently and see to it that you
utilize every second of this blessed
month a mean so Dr Zak Ramadan is a
month of opportunities it's a month of
blessed
opportunities what are the conditions
that a person needs to have these Deeds
accepted by Allah subhah wa tala the
basic two conditions are number one is
the
intention it should only be for Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and no one else
whatever deed you do it should only be
for Allah subhana wa tala and no one
else this is very important if this
condition is not met then all your Deeds
are wased and Allah subh says in the
Quran in Surah Bay chapter number 98
verse number five it says that you
worship none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and you do it only for him and for no
one
else it is further
mentioned in Surah insan chapter number
76 verse number n it
says that we have fed you for the sake
of Allah subhana wa tala for the pledge
of Allah subhana tala we do not require
any reward from you nor do you require
any returns that means if you feed
someone it is for the sake of Allah
subhana tala not seeking a reward or not
seeking anything in return this is a
very important factor that we should
note all your actions should be for the
sake of Allah subhana tala that's a very
important factor and further is
mentioned in the Quran in Surah sh
chapter number 42 verse number 20 that
if you do a deed for the Tilt for the
reward in the Hereafter Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala
will multiply your reward your tilt in
the yearafter and if you do a deed or
any action for a reward in this world
Allah will give you the reward in this
world but you'll have no share in the
Hereafter Allah repeated that message in
Surah HUD chapter number
11 verse number 15 and 16 that anyone
who sees the reward in this world or
does any deed for this world and for the
glitter of of this world Allah subhah wa
ta'ala will surely give him in this
world but he will have no share in the
Hereafter except fire except
hell and all his
deeds will not be useful in the yeara so
therefore whatever we do should be for
Allah subhana wa tala and the second C
of
Islam pleased with him it's mentioned
sari volume number oneith number one om
may Allah be pleased with him he
said that the Beloved Prophet M wasallam
said which means your Deeds are judged
on your
intention and the prophet further said
that all your actions are based on your
intention and anyone who has
migrated for Allah and hiso he has
migrated for Allah and his if if anyone
has an Hijra migrated for the worldly
benefits or for marriage he has migrated
for the worldly benefits and marriage so
ni is very important and this is further
repeated in another Hadith in say Muslim
number four Hadith number
7114 it says that our beloved Prophet M
wasallam said that Allah subh says that
I am alone sufficient I do not require
any associate and if anyone does any
deed for anyone else as well as for me I
renounce that for the person who he has
Associated to that means you can't do
part of the deed for Allah and part for
someone else you have to do completely
for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
only for him and no one else Allah does
not like anyone associating anything
with him that's very important so this
is a basic point that is the ni the
second point to be noted for our deed to
be acceptable is that our deed should be
based on the Sharia it should be in
accordance to Allah and his accordance
to the teachings of the Quran and
teachings of our beloved Prophet M
wasallam it's mentioned in s Muslim
number
three Hadith number
4267 where beloved Prophet Mall wasallam
said that if your deeds and actions are
not according to our way according to
the religion of Islam according to Quran
and sayith then that is rejected that
means for a deed to be accepted it
should be according to Quran
and and it's also mentioned in another
say had of Abu
daud volume number three Hadith number
4950 I beloved Prophet M wasallam
said that he told the people that follow
my example and the example of Kash
that's the rightly guided CIS so if you
follow them and cling to it with ey
teeth that means strongly follow it the
Sunnah of the prophet and my Sunnah the
prophet said that his Sunnah his way and
the way of the rash that is rightly
guided kis so for a deed to be accepted
a should be only for Allah subhana tala
and it should be according to the Shar
Quran and Subhan Allah for those answers
now alhamdulillah this is the part of
the show as we promise that if time
permitting we had time to uh receive
some of your questions relating to the
topic we would do so and we do have a
little bit of time so Dr Zakia why is it
that Ramadan specifically is put on its
own in terms of uh it being welcomed
what about other months like Hajj the
month of Hajj Etc the reason we Muslims
welcome the month of Ramadan
all the months in the year are good
alhamdulillah but the reason we
specifically welcome the month of
Ramadan because Ramadan is a month of
forgiveness it is a month where I
mentioned earlier our beloved Prophet
malli wasallam said that the doors of
heaven will be
opened the Gates of Hell will be closed
and the Devils will be changed so
because of this
reason this month is welcome and and
whatever deed we do it will be
multiplied 10 times the reward that we
get for every deed in this month is 10
times more because of this and whatever
we ask for forgiveness as our beloved
Prophet said that if we fast for the
full month of Ramadan with the true
intention and with proper Faith asking
reward from Allah subhana wa ta'ala all
our past will be forgiven mentioned
bukari Vol number three book of fasting
Hadith number 1901 so because of this
purpose
this month is welcomed so that we look
forward for our sins to be forgiven and
for our Deeds to be multiplied our Good
Deeds to be multiplied that is the
reason specifically we Muslims we
welcome this month of Ramadan mashallah
next question of quite equal importance
actually is about how people welcome
Ramadan with certain sayings Ramadan
Mubarak some people say it's a b and
others say it's a Sunnah what is your uh
ruling on
this to welcome month is good
alhamdulillah and our Prophet always
informed the other people about this
month and as I mentioned earlier that
our beloved Prophet M wasallam it's
mentioned in mus Ahmed R number two page
number
230 Hadith number 7148 which is also
repeated it is mention in sunai chapter
number five Hadith number 21106 that our
beloved prophet mallalli wasallam used
to always tell the people when the month
used to approach when it used to come
the prophet used to tell the people in
advance oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching
you and Allah subhana wa tala has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month so the prophet used to welcome
this month he used to wish other people
the same way today if you wish as the
prophet said the Blessed month is
approaching if someone says
Ramadan Mubarak this Ramadan Mubarak is
more often said in the Indian
subcontinent by the Indians by the
pakistanis because this word Mubarak
though Bara is an Arabic word Bara means
blessing and it is nothing but blessed
month but when the Indians and
pakistanis when they use the word
Mubarak it is more of a sort of
congratulation when someone passes
examination they sayak in U which you D
from the Arabic word bar so when comes
they wish Ramadan Mubarak saying that it
is the Blessed month or a sort of
congratulating and wishing each other
that the Blessed month is approaching so
according to me it's not a b you can
welcome the month it's a good thing that
you're calling this month a blessed
month and you're informing other people
reminding them that in this month is a
lot of blessing so according to me it's
not AA but how you wish the words you
choose that is muah that's optional like
in Indian subcontinent we use the word
Ramadan Mubarak in the Gulf countries
they use Ramadan Karim so all these
words are good the holy month or the
Blessed month or the month of
forgiveness so the choice of words is
yours but the prophet M Salli wasallam
he used to say to the people that oh
people the Blessed month of Ramadan is
approaching so I feel people should wish
each other and they should remind each
other about this blessed month
masallah Dr Zaki Nik that brings an end
to the questions unfortunately we don't
have more time otherwise you can answer
so many others that we've received on
email from our viewers PCV brothers and
sisters it has been an absolute pleasure
listening to Dr Zak nik's answers today
on let's welcome Ramadan tomorrow we'll
be discussing common errors which are
made by Muslims during the month of
Ramadan so I hope you'll join us
then
for
for for